uh here's the thing right the ending of
king in black is great
it is great and i will say this story is
probably one of the best venom stories
that i think i've ever read
and probably the single best venom story
ever written right like it's
it's this this story took venom from a
character that just exists and has done
some things
to a character that i genuinely care
about and i'm super interested to see
right so
uh the way this kicks off the way this
starts out is initially with the silver
surfer
right like initially starts off with a
silver only because of the fact that we
saw the silver surfer
arrive back on earth um and basically
you know
and tend to go toe-to-toe with with no
now a lot of this comes from the fact
that silver surfer and null had fought
against each other we covered that in
the in the silver surfer black story
the first time that he actually met null
and it was actually uh kind of sent back
in time to the early days of
of the universe but when he shows up
here it's really more of just biding
time
and there's a bit of a a funny
discussion here because the king of
blacks like
we've met before haven't we and he's
like yes indeed we have right and i
still remain
unimpressed and and because of the
conflict the two initially shared
and the fact that surfer was able to put
up such a such a strong fight against
noel
nola's like you know what i respect you
i mean i'm still gonna kill you but like
i respect you right like i will remember
you you won't just be a person
that will just kind of be disregarded as
just one of the many people that i've
killed over the course of my existence
and just don't really care anything
about uh the cool thing about this
is that like the response of surfer is
like i mean i may very well die here but
at the very least
i won't do it alone right and so you
basically end up having like
all these superheroes right essentially
like the avengers and the x-men banding
together
to face off against null the funny thing
about this is before they can
even get into the fight eddie brock
shows up right like
venom as captain universe like venom
became captain universe in the last
issue
and it's the craziest thing right
because from there it's like
here's one thing to understand right
here here's the thing to understand
about about captain universe and about
the enigma force so the enigma
force grants its user a wide array of
different abilities but more often than
not and really captain universe is just
kind of a plot device in the sense that
the only time you see captain universe
is when things are really popping off
now it doesn't mean the captain universe
sucks but there are limitations right
captain universe is not a character that
can compete with like
the molecule man owen reese or anything
along those lines somebody with the
power
to alter reality on like a universal
scale or even a multiversal scale
captain universe just isn't that
powerful right captain universe is a
powerful being
being able to channel cosmic energies
things along those lines but the
important thing here is that eddie brock
is on a whole new level of power
and by all standards of measurement
appears to be equal to null and we'll
find out why
but it's kind of nuts because null
initially looks at eddie and says like
there's like so this this is it
this is what you brought to me like this
is the the champion that's been selected
by the
by the the light of the universe a being
that i've killed
multiple times right this is the
champion that you chose
like could you have chosen a worse
person the reality yet is
is that it was the best person to choose
and the reason why is because eddie has
a personal vendetta against nol
but also having faced against him
multiple times and
lost he knows how to win but here's the
craziest thing that happens here eddie
brock
does two things he basically summons the
hammer of mjolnir away from thor now
here's the thing
it's one thing to be able to lift thor's
hammer we've seen that happen before
time and time again it's another to
summon it away from thor
we've never seen that before we've never
really seen someone summon thor's hammer
away from him right like where thor is
wielding it
and someone's like to me mjolnir and
they just take it away from him
that's nuts right and that's supposed to
be impossible it's supposed to be an
impossible feat
to be able to summon his hammer away
from him i cannot stress that enough
the second thing that that venom does is
he actually takes the surfboard of the
silver surfer
which is also thought to be impossible
because the the surfer
or the surfboard answers to the surfer
and the surfer only
there are individuals who can overpower
the board and who can keep the board
from returning to the silver surfer
but to just take it away from him like
that that's huge
and he basically ends up merging the
hammer of mjolnir and the
the the sword or the surfboard of surfer
which has been kind of
been modified into a sword he merges
them together
and creates a whole new weapon right
this like cosmic battle axe
and it's amazing dude it looks like
dude as soon as i saw that i was like oh
my god dude this thing is
lit it was it was cool it is super cool
right and so he's just like this is it
right this is us like it's just it's
just
me and no and what what follows is one
of the most spectacular
weapons in the history of comics this is
insane right it's absolutely amazing the
way this goes down
initially the x-men and everybody's just
like okay so um i just want to point out
here
that we just watched venom take thor's
hammer
away from him he just took it uh he just
took thor's hammer away from him and
then take the surfboard of the silver
surfer
and then merge them into a singular
weapon did we see that happen
and everybody's like yeah man uh we
kind of saw that happen and this and
everybody's just kind of like
okay venom's got this y'all
they just leave it to the venom right
and and literally this guy this this
man i'm saying something this guy's
cutting swathes right his swaths
are cutting swaths he's cutting swats
through everything right just swaths
swash all over the place just cutting
them all over the place right man it's
it's
man it's it's it's not even in hell
would you see a massacre like this right
i mean he's going he's running through
all these dragons just slicing them up
just slicing their heads off if i just
rip him to pieces
nose nose terrified for his life right
here i mean this this guy
this guy is just fleeing for his life
like it's it's the craziest thing
because
then like eddie rock runs up on him and
he's like no more right
no more swords no more dragons no more
none of that stuff
and noel doesn't understand how in the
world he's able to do this and then he's
like don't worry about how i'm able to
do it man just know that i can't right
and and literally noah's just just
panicking right just
panicking and it's one of these things
where where like literally he asked him
he
comes to eddie and he's like you know
nothing of darkness right but if you
want to know of darkness i will show you
darkness right is this
man magnetism it's a it's a crazy it's
the craziest
right so like so like no no it's like
dude man oh okay like whatever this
guy's got power who cares man whatever
like it's it's we'll let him do his
thing
right but at the end of the day like i
am null i'm king of the all-black i'm
not worried about some guy with a scythe
who has like a glowing logo on his chest
which looks lit
like i'm not worried about that guy
right so like literally summons one of
his celestials he's like you know what
i'll let the celestial take care of this
for me right i'll let the celestial
deal with this now son now son eddie
brock goes
flying up on this thing uses a scythe
and cuts his head clean off right
no it's just kind of like holy no nose
just nose like
dude dude eddie brock rasmull no he's
just he
he was not prepared and i'm sorry i'm so
excited people
but it is an exciting moment in the
story right it is an exciting moment in
this story man it is it's it's nuts
because he literally
like he tells him he's like i remember
everything right i remember all the all
the pain all the anguish that i've been
through all the times that i died
i remember every single symbiote that
was killed i remember every single ounce
of just
horror and struggle that i've been
through since you've shown up on this
world and started unleashing your holy
hell on everybody
null is in his pants right he's he's
just he's dude he's it's
it's it right eddie brock takes that
action just like sticks it right inside
no right just
jams it right inside his chest and then
strip some of his all black
right like strips him of his power right
just like takes him
takes his takes his power away from him
and then just
drops him right and instead of just like
leaving him to hit the ground while he
just like comes racing down
on top of him and he's like oh no no
he's like no son now son
we ain't done yet son like like duna man
it's it's
it's an ass weapon son like it's it's
it's nuts man it's just it's it's wild
it's it's
wild right so like the whole time nol's
like man you can't do this man you can't
do this and then he's like oh yes
i can yes i can he's like he's like nose
like dude even if you if you kill me
that's like it's not going to end right
the darkness will always live on and the
darkness
lives on in your son wrong answer son
wrong man
may he deep man he had to bring dylan in
he had to bring he had he had to say
something about eddie brock's son right
it's like eddie brock snatches him up
and he's like what's hold up my son
let's go talk so like literally he says
that let's go talk so he snatches him up
and then flies him into space right
flies him into space
and then just drops them off in the sun
he's like you may very well be right
right
that with all this happening that the
darkness may live on in my son
but in the end like the light will
always be there to slow it down so he's
just like this
is for dylan and just throws him into
the sun right just throws nola symbiote
god into the sun
and incinerates him right just watches
him burn to pieces
and then from there like he ends up
taking off back to earth now here's the
crazy thing that happens right the
captain universe entity the enigma force
chimes into eddie brock and he says like
do you feel it right and and eddie's
like yes right like i i hear
like all these voices right there
they're calling out to me but i can't
really understand them i don't really
know what's going on
and the endemic force is like you've
done it right these voices are singing
you destroyed null you freed all the
symbiotes the hive mind is now
free right like it's it's free and
capable of doing its own thing but like
when when eddie brock shows back up
again
uh the the axe of course lands back on
the ground you've got the silver surfer
and thor who kind of summon their own
respective weapons to them and of course
the battle axe ends up splitting
so you know the silver surfer gets the
sword back or i'm sorry gets his board
back
and uh and thor gets his gets mule near
back but when eddie brock shows back up
here
it's a a bit of a crazy thing because
with the whole thing
essentially being over and everything
being done you have dylan
who's struggling with all this right
because he can he can because of the
fact that
null is essentially a part of him he can
actually feel null burning in the sun
and eddie's response is i know it sucks
i know it's rough but bear with me for a
second this is going to hurt
and he reaches inside dylan and pulls
out the the portion of null
that exists inside of him right because
he's essentially kind of a living
symbiote to a degree
he pulls it out right like he pulls that
the darkness directly out of dylan
and then effectively incinerates it
right like basically destroys it and so
following that what ends up happening is
that you have the enigma force that is
just kind of like
good job eddie like you you basically
like you are now you are no longer just
eddie brock right you're no longer the
the venom that you used to be you
become something completely different
something else something new
right and so finally the the traditional
venom symbiote bonds itself back to
eddie brock
and then probably once what's the the
best conceivable ending to this story
right the best conceivable ending to the
story that you have the symbiote talking
to eddie and saying like i found you
right like can you feel it
do you know what's happened here and
eddie doesn't fully understand he
doesn't fully grasp
what it is has taken place but all the
symbiotes that are there
are looking to eddie now right and
eddie's like stay here right i'll be
right back i need to understand what's
going on
and the symbiote tells him you destroyed
no you
killed no all these voices are speaking
to you and you can't understand them to
the voices of the symbiotes
they're speaking to you in your ancient
language and your ancient tongue that
only a long-standing member of the
symbiote race can truly understand
but you freed your kind you're the hive
mind now right
you're the god of the symbiotes you are
the new king
in black with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end
don't worry this is not the definitive
ending of it all venom number 200 comes
out at some point relatively soon and
then we basically get the full-on
conclusion of the venom story right that
will wrap up
the entirety of donnie kate's run and
bring it to an end
but but i want to know what do you guys
think about the king and black event
because i'm not even going to lie
this was fantastic it was it was one of
the
best venom stories that i've ever read
it was amazing
dude it was it was absolutely amazing uh
but what do you guys think
right like what did you guys think about
this anyway guys we're gonna bring this
to an end if you guys are new here to
thomas explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
for if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later
you